[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey there i'm brian wood i'm the pr
manager here at wolfram
uh today i'm going to be speaking with
brad jaynes
who's the wolfram alpha math content
manager
he's here to talk a little bit about
what's new in wolframalpha notebook
edition
uh mostly math features and a little bit
about
you know what's new in wolfram alpha
itself so how you doing today brad
doing great thanks brian awesome so uh
tell us what what
it looks like uh wolf from alpha
notebook edition is just about a year
old
uh so how how does that feel
yeah it's pretty exciting it's um it's
one of
my most favorite projects that i've
worked on since i've been at wolfram
um it kind of marries the the
the unique features of both wolfram
alpha itself
and the uh the the notebook environment
that we have all grown used to
uh over the you know 35 plus years at
mathematica
right on so um i was going to say you
can maybe give people
a little bit of an idea of what that's
like but why don't we just dive into
your notebook and and you can show
people uh
sort of in real time what's what's up
sure yeah all right um so this is the
wolfram alpha notebook environment
um wolfram alpha notebook edition and
uh just like with wolframalpha
you can enter any of your
plain text english language queries and
it will
interpret them so anyways one of the
things that i was wanting to show off in
this talk
was uh some of the new developments that
we have made on the wolfram alpha math
team
for uh in our step-by-step step-by-step
is our most popular feature far and away
in wolfram alpha and here we have it
working natively
in the wolfram alpha notebook edition um
you can ask for you know any of the math
questions that you normally ask for
if you ask for show steps for them then
the the thing that gets returned is
those steps themselves
um so we can see uh you know here is an
area between curves
query um and this is one of our brand
new step-by-step features that we've
added um
i think just this spring so here we have
our
you know the the hints and the steps
that you would see on the website but
uh here we have them in line in the
notebook
and then you can kind of go through and
see
what the answer ends up being some of
our other steps programs that we have
we have angle between curves and we
added a couple new ones
both this norm vector norm
and some limit definition derivative
steps
um these two are extra exciting because
they were added by interns that we had
over the summer
oh well congratulations to them that's a
pretty cool accomplishment
yeah so you know just a few short months
here they're able to add
a step-by-step program not just for the
wolfram alpha website but it's also
working
in the notebook environment as well
excellent so
so these step-by-steps they look
very nice is is that the main point uh
or are there any
is there anything you can pull from
these that you can compute on further or
are these sort of just
self-contained little uh sort of
tutorials
if that makes sense right yeah the the
step-by-step themselves are
are designed to kind of walk you through
how a human
uh or a student studying that material
um
how they might compute that uh if
they're doing it by hand
so there's not really anything we can do
to kind of chain this in with another
query
um but uh you know
right but in theory you could you could
go through these steps and wolfram alpha
would understand
you know if you're entering it in there
you could get a lot of those same
yeah and if you're in results if you're
not asking first steps you can
you can ask for just the angle between
the vectors and you can get that
end result then and then do subsequent
computations with it
okay makes sense
all right so so what else uh aside from
the step-by-step what are some other new
features that you've got here
um so one of the other cool things that
we've done with
uh the wolfram alpha notebook edition is
uh
made more use of the wolfram function
repository
so there's a lot of things that uh
in in the wolfen alpha notebook edition
what we try to do is convert
a user's query a user's input into a
wolfram language function but some
things
especially things that we have in
wolfram alpha
they don't already have a direct wolfram
language analog
so that's where the function repository
comes in where
anyone including either you know
developers or
hobbyists or anybody can create their
own function and it can
be added to the system uh essentially as
a wolfram language symbol
so um here's one of the more neat ones
that we that our team has worked on
this curve analysis feature and um
what it does is it makes this nice
colorful interactive plot
that lets you kind of highlight
different features of
a particular function okay and this is
computed live
as soon as you run the query so if you
wanted to kind of highlight what's one
period of this
particular function or you know say
you're studying calculus and you wanted
to
[Music]
explore the the relationship between the
derivative and the stationary points you
can turn both of those
features on and see oh the stationary
points which are these these little
diamonds
they represent where the derivative
function which is this kind of dashed
line
line where it crosses the x-axis so you
can see that relationship
nice and easy um yeah yeah it's very
neat
yeah so this seems like i mean this
almost looks like the kind of diagram
that
you might see on like a slideshow in
class like during a lecture
um except it's it's kind of a little
more interactive
i guess uh which which i think is always
a good way to learn things
just just be able to look around at it
for sure
and you can kind of turn things on and
off depending on on what you're
what exactly you're looking for um you
can change the background you can add
like a drop down
uh with the mouse over yeah i really
like the the black background and
nice um you can do some drop lines here
uh so it'll it'll kind of show where
you're at on the
the main curve there wow okay
yeah uh it's pretty cool
yeah and and then for different
functions it will it might highlight
different
kinds of properties right you know sine
is
is a typical curve that will show your
derivative and integral
um here's one that also has some things
like discontinuities or
uh limits or derivatives or asymptotes
and things like that so wow
so that's it seems like that uh that
curve analysis is a pretty comprehensive
function then it
does a lot of heavy lifting there that's
yeah that's very nice um and it's
again it's it's using the wolfram
function repository so
uh anyone has access to this particular
function
um whether you're in the wolf alpha
notebook edition or just in a normal
wolfram language notebook whether that's
on the cloud or
um in your mathematica environment
yeah and and in this case uh it's
interesting that uh
the the code almost looks exactly like
the
natural language query that you've got
up there it's uh
you know it's just a few small
differences so right
typically or pretty much the only
additional thing is
this second argument here which is just
specifying what is the independent
variable for this particular function
function x exactly right now
all right so uh what else what else do
we have here
um one of the things that i find most
interesting about the wolfman alpha
notebook edition
is again the ability to do uh kind of
sequential computations
um and here's one and i'm a little
afraid to evaluate because of the
the connectivity issues we're having
earlier um but this is a problem from a
computer math uh competition exam
um typically this is a
competition where people are using
different programming languages to
to kind of answer these really
complicated questions
um so in this case the question was
something along the lines of
uh what is the maximum value of this of
the determinant of this four by four
matrix
um on a given interval um
and typically like that that's that's
definitely too complicated of a thing
that you can ask
wolfram alpha in one line you know
but here uh we're able to do it and and
just three
kind of questions here um so the first
one we're
we're defining that that matrix um that
four by four matrix as
this variable m and then we're setting
f to be the determinant of m and again
all i'm doing is typing in what you
would
uh you know what you would say out loud
or what you're doing
in your head to do this problem and then
i just say you know max
max of f for x between these two uh
numbers and um in just a couple seconds
uh we're able to understand what you
meant convert it to wolfram language
syntax and then spit out the answer here
right so so not only can you um sort of
chain
commands one to the next uh you can sort
of
keep things in memory the way that you
would with uh
well with programming or if you're using
a calculator for instance
uh so it seems like there's there's a
lot of
sort of the same functionality that you
might want from
you know any calculator or math tool all
sort of built in but
in a very intuitive way so you can just
say it the way that you would normally
say it yeah
exactly um i feel the wolfram language
already has a pretty low barrier of
entry
like the function that that computes the
maximum
value of a of a expression is called
maximize
um but sometimes like the ordering of
the syntax and when you need brackets
and things like that is a little
confusing and ambiguous especially to
someone who's new to programming
i think the wolf from alpha notebook
edition completely removes the
that even that small barrier of entry
that there is to
um to perform some really high level
computation
yeah yeah and it's it's pretty
impressive the things that you can get
just from that that sort of simple
workflow
um so is there anything else uh
in wolfram alpha notebook edition that
might be new
to some people that they haven't seen
before
yeah um one of the things that uh has
been a big influence
in uh
important addition uh in the last year
um
has been uh the expansion of our
scientific content um so i'm just the
the math manager like
uh i we kind of stick in number land on
my team but
um we work uh pretty collaboratively
with
the the other science departments and
the step-by-step for chemistry has
really come a long way in the last year
there's a recent blog post series by by
jason sonnenberg
who's the the primary step-by-step
developer and
uh and a lot of that stuff is uh let's
just say on its way to the wolfram alpha
notebook edition as well
um you can already do queries for for
various chemical properties and things
and
uh kind of hooking in the the step right
the step-by-step
for those as well like we have for math
content um
right should be here in in the next week
or two so cool
yeah yeah so it'll be useful in
chemistry class as well
yeah absolutely solving solving chemical
equations
instead of uh just mathematical ones all
right
cool so lots of interesting new features
um
so aside from just the function
repository resources
what other kinds of things are available
through that resource system
in in the notebook edition sure uh one
of the other
uh wolfram technologies that we've made
use of is the
the very popular wolfram demonstrations
project
so uh if i could share again to access
this in the wolfmelford notebook edition
it's as easy as asking for
uh demonstrations on a particular
subject so here i've
i've typed in uh derivatives
demonstrations and one of the
suggestions you get is an entity list of
that
click on that and then you get this
whole swath of things you can click on
wow yeah um i just clicked on this
graphs of taylor polynomials one
so this is something you know kind of
computes the the various taylor
polynomial of a function
um you can change the degree so you can
get more or less
curves here uh and then changing the
domain and range on this
this graph and see the different
behavior uh
pretty neat and again just from a single
query that that's what i was able to
get so yeah yeah and like i said with
the other one this this interactive
stuff just seems
really useful for anyone trying to
actually learn these concepts because
i definitely remember getting pretty
confused about taylor polynomials
and uh calc ii so yeah definitely
yeah so again one more uh really neat
thing that the wolf alpha notebook
edition can do that
that we can't quite do on the website
itself so
um you know we have some interactive
elements on the website but
nothing compares to what you can do
within a notebook right yeah
awesome well thank you for uh for
showing me some of this stuff that's new
and will from alpha notebook edition
um of course got new math new
step-by-step
interactive stuff resource access so
hopefully people are enjoying using it
and uh
definitely recommend any any students or
teachers out there
trying to figure out a good way to run
you know math courses or
even just work on a math homework the
wolfram alpha notebook edition
yeah for sure thanks so much thanks for
joining us
you can check out other wolfram tech
talks live coding streams and more
on the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com